out the pious and the grateful a thank
you marking recovery good fortune or
success in Mexico they're called X
votive paintings delivered to the church
a devotion or gift after prayers were
answered
those who wanted their story to be known
ordered these little paintings they were
made by artists that worked near the
churches people told them their story
and they would interpret it paint it and
wrote a few lines about it at the bottom
of the painting the idea of giving gifts
and thanks has been around for thousands
of years and even as the survey see the
Mexico is becoming less religious that
are still those commissioning paintings
to mark what they see as divine
intervention one of the artists most
in-demand is Alfredo veal chest from a
small studio in a working-class area in
the west of Mexico City he's been
painting for more than 30 years he
started after losing his job as a
builder I started doing what I thought I
could do drawing in small pieces of
paper cardboard in Soto lives in sardine
cans anywhere and at some point I went
to sell them on the street and that was
it it's difficult to start as an artist
people give thanks for many things
recovery from illness a man being
released from prison after a cow he was
accused of stealing turned up a
prostitute who wanted more customers
praying for someone's return after the
9/11 attacks in New York as an X photo
painter I hear many stories but my
favorites are love stories given thanks
for having found the love of their life
because this partner came back when she
thought it was over
those are nice because the fillings are
nice there are always second chances a
friend whose work is always in demand
he said exhibitions in Canada Germany
and even if the world-famous Louvre in
Paris but his greatest joy creating for
those who live nearby for those who want
a permanent reminder of the day when
their prayers were answered
Alan Fisher al Jazeera Mexico City